des injonctions qui sont faites aux
femmes on en parle souvent ici les
injonctions il ya quelques jours une
quarantaine de femmes se sont réunis à
paris pour défiler contre les diktats de
la beauté
elle dénonce notamment un manque de
diversité en matière de taille de
vêtement de l'industrie de la mode les
grandes gueules de rmc story les ont
rencontrés je fais du 44 46 pour trouver
quelque chose de sexy de brancher à des
prix attractifs ses limites
impossible c'est très compliqué en
france le marché grande taille est
vraiment minime
et en sachant que la femme en moyenne
fait une taille 42 et au delà du 42e il
ya 40% de cette femme là qu'il faille 44
et qui ne peuvent même pas s'habiller
dans les marques de grande distribution
les marques les plus connues on a un
réel problème en fait alors on a un réel
problème avec ces marques qui décide que
on s'arrête au 40 parce que ce ne serait
pas bien d'avoir des clientes qui font
du 42 44 46 on imagine que c'est à la
politique de la maison visiblement
caroline qu'est ce que vous en pensez
alors ce que j'en pense c'est un petit
peu vous mettez la même situation que
damien est à 5 minutes avec les
allocations par des sujets bars et des
sujets où évidemment ça va déraper très
vite pourquoi ce que c'est des sujets
qui sont à bout mais moi ce que ce que
j'ai envie de dire c'est que les
injonctions
elles sont partout elles sont sur les
filles qui sont trop minces elles sont
sur les filles qui sont un petit peu
trop ronde et elles sont aussi sur les
boutiques et sur les marques donc
laissons les boutiques faire ce qu'elles
veulent s'y à une boutique au visage un
jeune pas ses critiques denis et ses
marques dis moi j'arrête aux 40 parce
que ma cliente je veux qu'elle soit
n'est absolument pas avant qu'en fait
les boutiques et les marques elles ont
aussi en tête une certaine esthétique
elles se disent moi mes vêtements ça va
lui créer nation caroline marx et là
c'est de la discrimination c'est à dire
que telle elle m'a aidé c'est notre
choix c'est un choix qui vient de la
marque qui dit moi ce que je crée j'ai
l'impression que ça va mieux aller à un
certain type de morphologie
alors il se trouve que là c'est les
mains pas de bol évidemment on va se
faire taper dessus mais c'est l'enfer
c'est vrai aussi qu'il ya des y ait des
choses vont mieux au rhône et il ya des
choses qui vont mieux je pense à des
années les morphologies
je suis désolé tout le monde veut pas
porter la même chose et les marques ont
le droit d'avoir un serment vous
dédouanez certaines mortelles tendance
qui disent ce qu'ils ne disent pas
ouvertement qu'elles sont grosso fin
parce qu'elle sait pas bien de le dire
mais deux mais qui du coup ne met pas en
vente dès leurs vêtements au delà du 40
par exemple elles font ce qu'elles
veulent elle est due à son gré je suis
désolé il n'y a aucun progrès c'est de
pire en pire les grandes marques
effectivement assez hideux et sérieuse
en du bo non je suis désolé il ya
certaines marques on le sait très bien
qu'il ne faut pas de taille au dessus du
cac 40 ce n'est pas elle veut décider si
moi j'ai envie de me mettre dans telle
ou telle marque
c'est à moi de décider si tel ou tel
truc me vint ou pas et suis désolé ces
mois difficiles d'ici noël
c'est incroyable parce que c'est la
discrimination c'est la vie et vous
savez maintenant c'est très grave car
haut et je comprends pas comment tu peux
voilà dire que il
pas de souci avec ça voilà et bah dites
nous ce que vous en pensez avec le
hashtag cqdm qu'est-ce que vous êtes
plutôt du du côté de caroline qui dit
après tout les marques font ce qu'elles
veulent elles peuvent choisir entre
guillemets leurs clientes et les
personnes qu'elle qu'elle habille ou
comme emilie qui dit c'est à moi de
décider si je me sens bien ou pas dans
tel ou tel vêtement et c'est pas à la
marque de choisir hashtag et sécu des lt